all right y'all before we go i have one
last story that might make you smile
this is what i'm liking
earlier we talked about our love for
books something many of us share that
also includes a utah woman who went
viral for creating mini books check this
out was it absolutely necessary to make
tiny replicas of the books that i've
read over the last year just so that i
could put them in hr and have a visual
representation of my own accomplishments
for my own validation
no no it was not necessary do i regret
spending two and a half hours of my
night last night making them
also no they are my favorite thing when
i regret nothing
she needs
a show she's so funny they look adorable
and after the video went viral her inbox
was flooded with messages asking how she
made them and probably just as many as
saying how funny she is we have stevie
on the line right now who watches on ksl
tv in salt lake city
what's up stevie
hi
you i have to lead with yes this is such
a cool idea but you are so funny your
comedic timing is on point ma'am thank
you
so so where did you get the idea from
well you know i'd i'd seen a similar
trend with uh christmas ornaments and
people were tracking the books that they
had read uh like in a christmas ornament
and it was it it inspired me because i
have this kind of silly problem where
like only half of the books that i read
are like the physical book
and the rest are digital or um audible
and i know
that that's a hot take and that some
people are gonna say that doesn't count
as reading but it is my jar and it
counts
but this was like this was the perfect
solution for that right like i could
have my auto audible audio books my
digital books nobody knows the
difference uh so that's where i kind of
got the idea um but i i played around
with the design i i figured out how i
wanted to make them and then
i spent a night and a
bottle of wine making them i made a
little over 20 of them i think
and i've added to it since then in fact
we have a we have a new
we have a new addition to the to the jar
yes
the netflix series now
i highly recommend fantastic book
i love that i actually love you read the
dutch house the midnight library i love
those two i read those as well i was
trying to i was peeking at all your
books while i was looking thank you so
much stevie i'm liking your post right
now but i'm loving you
[Applause]
that's not all our season long partner
pilot pin makers of g2 the go-to pin of
the kelly clarkson show want to honor
ultimate overachievers just like you
ma'am so they're going to be writing you
a check for a thousand dollars just
because we think you're cool
all right thank you so much tv have a
good day
[Music]
you